that person is successful that person  surely must have been very lucky have  you ever heard other people talk about  successful people like this with success  often there is lack involved these  people who are at the right time at the  right place to make that work that  doesn't mean that success is always  determined by external factors where  surely there's one concept I want to  share with you today and this is the  surface area of luck if you want to be  lucky as well to become successful  expose yourself to situations where you  might find that luck stand up meet new  people pursue new project make sure you  always over deliver on your work read  new books expose yourself to new  situations one way that for sure will  not help you to become lucky and  successful is just to sit at home and  complain how you were never Lucky in  success never came to you what do you  think about this let me know in the  comments and follow for more careers  content